Well, we are back, it is 20, 21, it is great
to be back with you and there is just so much
to talk about that I think these last few weeks
for Donald Trump. As we get to the end, these
may be the craziest. Let's just get right into
it. Donald Trump has now been caught on an audio
recording of a phone call pressuring the Georgia
Republican Secretary of state, Brad Raffensperger,
to, quote, recalculate the election results
in Georgia in order to find about 11000 votes
for Donald Trump. And everything about this is
absolutely nutty. The Washington Post obtained a
recording of Donald Trump urging Georgia Secretary
of State Brad Raffensperger to find a way to give
Donald Trump the victory. In Georgia, of course,
won by Joe Biden, the current president elect,
and Donald Trump. On this phone call we're going
to listen to is speaking not just to Republican
Secretary of State Brad Raffensperger, but also
to the secretary of state's general counsel,
Donald Trump's chief of staff, Mark Meadows.
Also on the call. It's an hour long call. The
phone call is available for you. We're
just going to listen to a few clips.
And this is really something else. So please
understand what this audio shows as if we
didn't know it is that the president of the United
States is leading a campaign, a pressure campaign
against democratic elections in order to remain
in power despite the results of that election.
Here is the first clip Donald Trump asks
Raffensperger to please recalculate.
We have won this election in Georgia based on all
of this. And there's nothing wrong with saying
that bread. You know, I mean, having having
a correct if the people of Georgia are angry
and these numbers are going to be repeated
on Monday night along with others that we're
going to have by that time, which are much more
substantial even. And the people of Georgia are
angry, the people of the country are angry. And
there's nothing wrong with saying that, you know,
that you've recalculated.
Well, Mr. President,
the challenge that you have
is the data you have is wrong.
Now, do you think it's possible that they
shredded ballots in Fulton County because
that's what the rumor is and also that
Dominion took out machines, that Dominion
is really moving fast to get rid of their.
Machinery, do you know anything about that?
Because that's illegal in Germany, no dominion
has not moved any machinery out of Fulton County,
where have they moved you?
Have they have they moved the
inner parts of the machines and
replaced them with other parts?
No, he's you're right, I'm sure, so just no
to everything, to every one of Donald Trump's
notions, they on the call saying, no, no, it's
just that this isn't the case. That's not the
case. And Trump, you know that little. Are you
sure from Trump that's like a mob boss type of.
Are you sure? Because it would really be a
shame if something were to happen to this
beautiful family of yours after being told none
of this is happening. Donald Trump pulls out the
big one and starts speaking in more clear terms,
says, I just need you to find 11000, 780 votes.
And they are removing machinery and
they're moving it as fast as they can,
both of which are criminal fines.
And you can't let it happen and you
are letting it happen. You know, I mean, I'm
notifying you that you're letting it happen.
So like, oh, I want to do
is this I just want to find
eleven thousand seven hundred eighty votes, which
is one more that we have because we won the state.
When we say high crimes and misdemeanors, this
is exactly under that umbrella. That is the ask.
I need you to find eleven thousand seven hundred
and eighty votes so that I win Georgia. And Trump
says it again later. He says, Come on, guys,
give me a break. I only need 11000 votes here.
So what? So what are we going to do
if I only need 11000 votes? I promise
I need 11000 votes. Give me a break.
This is criminal presidential obstruction
in an election where Trump himself is
a candidate. It's not Trump obstructing
some other election between two people other
than him. He's a candidate in this election,
it is actually hard to find something a
president can do that is worse than this
in terms of its impact on the democratic systems.
I know you know, there are other things that have
a death toll that we assign, which are much more
gruesome in nature for sure. And killing people
in in many ways is, of course, worse than
making a phone call during which you ask
someone to cheat for you from the standpoint of
what it does to the pillars of democracy, this is
almost as bad a thing as a president can do. The
call is nuts. And Trump kind of switches between
attacking and criticizing Raffensperger and
trying to sort of placate him and flatter him.
It's very weird. Take a look at this last clip.
We won the election and it's not fair to take
it away from us like this. And it's going
to be very costly in many ways. And I think
you have to say that you're going to reexamine
it and you can reexamine it. But but reexamine
it with people that want to find answers,
not people that don't want to find answers.
For instance, I'm hearing,
Ryan, that he's probably.
I'm sure a great lawyer and everything,
but he's making statements about
those ballots that he doesn't know when he's
making it was said he did make a majority,
but now I think he's less sure because
the answer is they all went to bed
and that alone wins the election by a lot.
You know, you have people that submit information
and we have our people that submit information,
and then it comes before the court and the court
then has to make a determination. We have to stand
by our numbers. We believe our numbers are right.
Well, under the law, you're not allowed
to give faulty election results,
OK? You're not allowed to do that. And that's what
you've done. This is a faulty election result.
This really is like nothing we have seen
before. It's not an exaggeration. This is
not this is unlike anything we've seen
in the United States. Carl Bernstein,
I believe saying that this is far worse
than Watergate. Dan Rather saying this
is far worse than Watergate. We've seen
this stuff in other countries, no doubt,
but we've not seen it like this in the United
States. An ethical moral person would say.
I think maybe the count is wrong, count the votes
and give us the results, Trump says. Come on,
guys, give me a break. I need 11000 votes.
The difference could not be more stark.
Now, trumpets are split of two minds on this.
Right now. There are some Trampas who are playing
coy and they're saying Trump didn't do anything
wrong. Trump said, calculate the correct results,
which we won with. I believe if you listen to
the call, it's very hard to make that case. Trump
is very clearly saying something different.
He's saying regardless of the real results.
Come on, guys, give me a break. I need 11000
votes. Other Trump ists who can't make that
dumb argument I just mentioned are
just pretending this isn't going on.
If you look at some pro Trump enclaves on the
Internet, they've been immediately deleting all
references to this story, removing all links to
this story as quickly as they're being posted,
they're being deleted. They're just suppressing
the story altogether. So is anybody surprised by
this? The guy who said to Ukraine, dig up dirt
on Biden for me? No, we can't be surprised by
this. Now, a quick word on Brad Raffensperger.
There's been some praise of Brad Raffensperger
floating around for holding firm here. And,
you know, he did he didn't bow to Trump's
pressure. And it takes some strength when the
president, who happens to be from your own party
is telling you what to do. It takes some strength
to say no. But remember that this election didn't
come down to just Georgia. When this phone
call took place. It was clear that even if
Brad Raffensperger could somehow steal Georgia for
Trump, Trump still doesn't win the election. So I
am wondering I don't know. I'm wondering, would
Raffensperger and Brian Kemp from Georgia,
would they have held this firm if flipping Georgia
would have given Trump the presidency? I don't
know the answer to that. I'm just asking. Trump's
participation certainly justifies impeachment and
removal. We have 16 days left in this presidency.
Trump will be gone before impeachment could
happen. You can impeach a president after they've
left office. It's warranted. I doubt it will
happen, but completely impeachable behavior.
There is a reason that companies often escort
former employees out of the building right away
with presidents. It's never been necessary before.
It's different with Trump. And that's
sort of the final thought on this.